where do we get
marriage wrong like
i don't even know if most most men even
know like the purpose of getting married
like what we're looking for are we
confused half the time when we're
getting married
yes to be fair and honest um both sexes
tend to fall in love with the members of
the other sex who are they
who are often opposites and and often
the least capable of loving them
so men fall in love with beautiful
younger women who are less mature uh
than they are and end up um
being very highly you know look
looking up to the man at the beginning
and we feel really proud and approved of
and so on uh but then it turns out that
we're a little bit disgusted at their
lack of maturity and they're disgusted
at our uh propensity for dominating and
um and having all the answers and the
more mature she becomes the more she
wants to have an equality in the
relationship which was different from
the dynamic that attracted the two of
them
but there's a lot of bigger issues that
often happen here too so in the jeff
bezos case i don't know the situation
personally but normally speaking or very
frequently as a sort of model um the the
woman will initially be attracted to a
man who is very successful powerful
confident in himself able to be has a
sense of efficacy um and so um but she
doesn't realize that it's ex
it's exactly those characteristics
that will lead to their divorce here's
why
so um
what both sexes have an equal need for
is a need to feel heard and understood
but as the male um who is successful
becomes more and more successful he
often learns a series of behaviors that
are
that are that help him become successful
at work
that is are exactly the behaviors that
lead him to be unsuccessful in love so
for example let's say you're a ceo and
you're looking for a a new type of plane
and you get a sales person trying to
sell you a special engine um that they
have for a new plane that will that they
say will be perfect for you well as as a
ceo you're listening to that um sales
person speak and you're thinking to
yourself okay is this salesperson is um
convincing as another salesperson i had
before and should i also interview
somebody else will this work for my
chinese market well will this work for
these infrastructure that i already have
set up for my chinese market uh will
this um you know and and is asking a
hundred questions like this while the
person is talking
um and so
that person the a good ceo has learned
his self listen
um to be juggling the listening process
with the um with the yes but process or
what about process and the
cross-examination process
that skill set for the good ceo becomes
so ingrained
that when he takes that that skill set
home and by the way this can sometimes
be happened to women as well
not as frequently but i'll explain why
both frequently and not frequently so
that the male sales of the male ceo
comes home and his wife says you know
i've had a really difficult day at work
or i've had a difficult day with the
children where something's happened in
the family and um and the male
sees his wife the woman he loves the
woman he'd probably die for to is having
a problem and so our instinct when our
wife is having a problem is to while
she's talking to figure out a solution
because instinctively when our wife who
i we love is bleeding to death the only
way to handle that is to solve the
problem to get the band-aids on her
quickly to get it to the emergency room
quickly and so um we we're we're
behaving with our wife in a way
that is looking for the solution while
she's talking
very few ceos or top-level entrepreneurs
realize that there is a solution for
your wife's complaints
and challenges and that is to listen
not only listen by keeping your mouth
shut
but also listen by when she's finished
the complaining
not coming up with a solution
but rather saying so sweetie what i
heard you say was was this is and then
asking is that accurate and then if she
says no actually it's mostly accurate
thank you for listening but i think you
got this wrong not saying no no i said
that
not becoming defensive about what she
feels we got wrong but being right in
there saying so it's not what i said but
it's this is that correct and then she
goes yes that's correct okay did i miss
anything in
understanding what you're saying
um yes i think you've missed this no no
no i think i got that i said that
because this no
shut your mouth listen
work on what she feels you missed
because the only thing that counts
is what she feels that you've missed and
then when she begins to feel safe
because you didn't distort anything you
didn't miss anything say is there
anything new that you'd like to add
that leads to a woman or when a woman
does the same thing for a man in reverse
that leads to your partner feeling heard
but the great majority of men
move to fixing the problem
as opposed to understanding that you can
fix the problem
by not fixing the problem the fixing of
the problem is the listening process
hearing um and then letting your wife or
your daughter or your son
um say
here's what i heard you say son
daughter wife
mom dad um and then mom and dad daughter
wife
uh fia son feels really heard
and then
and being open to anything you distorted
opened anything that you missed and so
this is what i teach in my couple's
communication courses in much greater
depth that i've explained here and
invariably one of the men in the course
will say well no i'm not really fixing
it then i'm not really attending to
her real need she's hurting why am i not
solving the problem for her and i have
to work with him and hearing the
listening process
in the way i just described it is the
solution
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you